the death toll has risen overnight and
that massive explosion in beirut the
death toll has climbed
to more than 100 people this morning
it's said to be the most
powerful blast ever seen in a city that
was nearly destroyed in a 15-year civil
war
officials believe thousands of tons of
ammonium nitrate a fertilizer chemical
often used in bombs
was detonated by a burning warehouse
full of fireworks
charlie dagoda has new information on
the explosion charlie those
images out of beirut are just
devastating
incredible there are reports this
morning now of more than 4
000 injured that number is expected to
climb as the search for survivors
continues
officials are blaming the explosion on
thousands of tons of ammonium nitrate as
you mentioned
used as fertilizer usually but also to
make bombs
now there are serious questions as to
why such a dangerous quantity the
chemical
was being stored so close to the city
center
an initial explosion sent a towering
plume of smoke high into the
air the inferno engulfing nearby
buildings
then it triggered something much much
bigger
the massive blast created a mushroom
cloud of debris
dust and smoke that swept through the
city
to the explosion as seen from the bay a
blast
so powerful it was felt in countries
more than a hundred miles away
i don't know how my neighborhood just
became a war zone
debris and shards of glass from
shattered windows
became shrapnel flying through the air
at lightning speed before people could
duck for cover you guys still don't even
know what happened yet
bloodied survivors stumbled through the
debris
everyone who was able became a first
responder
journalist gada asharif was at her desk
when the second explosion blew the
office windows in
everybody was just screaming get down
completely covered and
in debris buildings destroyed um
and bodies being you know lifted from
under
cars blood everywhere
the city's hospitals already struggling
to cope with covid19 were quickly
overwhelmed
only those with life-threatening
injuries allowed in
the lebanese prime minister said 2 700
tons
of ammonium nitrate had blown up stored
for
years in a portside warehouse president
trump said
his generals thought maybe it wasn't an
accident they seemed to think it was a
attack it was a bomb of some kind yes
the blast laid waste to the port in a
country that imports almost
all of its food and 85 percent of its
grain had been stored in the destroyed
granaries
now before the blast lebanon was already
in a coveted 19 lockdown before that
widespread po protests were demanding
the resignation of the government
here the uk's joined the united states
the u.n and even traditional adversary
israel
in offering international support and
assistance
jeff charlie in london thank you very
much